jane is relaxing at home when she
receives an email from a bank that asks
her to update her credit card pin in the
next 24 hours as a security measure
judging the severity of the message jane
follows the link provided in the email
on delivering her current credit card
pin and the supposedly updated one
the website became unresponsive which
prompted her to try sometime later
however after a couple of hours she
noticed a significant purchase from a
random website on that same credit card
which she never authorized
frantically contacting the bank jane
realized the original email was a
counterfeit or a fake message with a
malicious link that entailed credit card
fraud
this is a classic example of a phishing
attack
phishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted source
its basic purpose is to trick the victim
into revealing sensitive information
like passwords and payment information
it's based on the word fishing which
works on the concept of baits
if a supposed victim catches the bait
the attack can go ahead which in our
case makes jane the fish and the
phishing emails the bait
if jane never opened the malicious link
or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively ineffective
but how does the hacker gain access to
these credentials
a phishing attack starts with a
fraudulent message which can be
transmitted via email or chat
applications
even using sms conversations to
impersonate legitimate sources is known
as smishing which is a specific category
of phishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible
once the victims submit information
using the link via the password or
credit card details the data is sent to
the hacker who designed the email and
the fake website giving him complete
control over the account whose password
was just provided
often carried out in campaigns or an
identical phishing mail sent to
thousands of users the rate of success
is relatively low but never zero between
2013 and 2015 corporate giants like
facebook and google were tricked off of
100 million dollars due to an extensive
fishing campaign where a known common
associate was impersonated by the
hackers apart from credit access some of
these campaigns target the victim device
and install malware when clicked on the
malicious links
which can later function as a botnet or
target for ransomware attacks
there is no single formula for there are
multiple categories of phishing attacks
the issue with jane or the hacker stoler
bank credentials falls under the
umbrella of deceptive phishing
a general email is sent out to thousands
of users in this category hoping some of
them fall prey to the scam
spear phishing on the other hand is a
bit customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the netflix team sends it
becomes pointless
this is a potential drawback of
deceptive phishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry
the hacker can send counterfeit messages
to the target user while implying the
source of such messages being spotify
tricking them into sharing private
information
since the hacker already knows the
target uses spotify the chances of
victims taking the bait increase
substantially
for more important targets like ceos and
people with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10 full which can be
called a case of whaling the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their phishing attack
often to steal industry secrets for
rival companies or sell them off at a
higher price
apart from just emails farming focuses
on fake websites that resemble their
original counterparts as much as
possible the prevalent method is to use
domain names like facebook with a single
o or youtube with no e
these are mistakes that people make when
typing the full url in the browser
leading them straight to a counterfeit
web page which can fool them into
submitting private data
a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like arp
spoofing and dns cache poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource constraints
now that we know how phishing attacks
work let's look at ways to prevent
ourselves from becoming victims
while the implications of a phishing
attack can be extreme protecting
yourself against these is relatively
straightforward
jane could have saved herself from
credit card fraud had she checked the
link in the email for authenticity and
that it redirected to a secure website
that runs on the https protocol
even suspicious messages shouldn't be
entertained
one must also refrain from entering
private information on random websites
or pop-up windows irrespective of how
legitimate they seem
it is also recommended to use secure
anti-phishing browser extensions like
cloudfish to sniff out malicious emails
from legitimate ones
the best way to prevent phishing is
browsing the internet with care and
being on alert for malicious attempts at
all times
so here is a question for you
if both me and my friends receive the
same email that instructs us to change
our spotify password before the end of
the day even though one of us never used
spotify
what bracket does this fishing attack
fall under
one whaling
two
spear fishing three deceptive fishing
four
farming
think about it and leave your answers
below in the comments section and three
lucky winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
cyber attacks are becoming more
prevalent due to the pandemic where work
from home is the norm and people spend
possibly more than half their day with a
laptop but we cannot stop every attack
at the root we must be informed and
vigilant to fishing attacks among others
to safeguard our data
we hope you enjoyed this video if you
did a thumbs up would be really
appreciated here's your reminder to
subscribe to our channel and click on
the bell icon for more on the latest
technologies and trends thank you for
watching and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
[Music]
you